The original Star Wars trilogy remains one
of the most successful and popular film series
in history.
So when it came time to cast the prequels
in the late '90s, George Lucas had a tall
task ahead of him — and his casting choices
didn't always pan out.
Whether you love or hate the Star Wars prequels,
though, there's no denying the franchise might
have been very different if some of the big
name stars Lucas had considered were in the
films instead.
Here's a look at some of the A-list celebrities
who were almost in the Star Wars prequels.
Leonardo DiCaprio as Anakin Skywalker
By the time Attack of the Clones began filming
in 2000, Leonardo DiCaprio had become the
hottest young heartthrob in Hollywood with
films like Titanic.
DiCaprio met with Lucas about playing Anakin
Skywalker in the second and third Star Wars
prequels, but ultimately turned down the role
because, despite his superstar status, he
didn't feel ready for the kind of attention
that Star Wars would bring.
It was the second time he almost romanced
Natalie Portman on screen: she was originally
cast opposite DiCaprio in Romeo + Juliet,
but dropped out because she was so young at
the time that her scenes with DiCaprio were
unintentionally creepy.
Good thing she avoided all that creepy romance,
right?
Oh, wait.
“I’m haunted by the kiss that you should
never have given me.
My heart is beating, hoping that that kiss
will not become a scar.”
Whoops.
Christian Bale as Anakin Skywalker
Years before Christian Bale donned Batman's
iconic cape and cowl, he was almost a very
different type of dark knight.
In the lead-up to Attack of the Clones, Lucasfilm
casting director Robin Gurland reviewed over
700 tapes, hoping to find the perfect Anakin
Skywalker.
One name that reportedly came up: Christian
Bale, who had worked with George Lucas' close
friend Steven Spielberg on Empire of the Sun,
and was coming off a critically acclaimed
performance as a gleefully murderous businessman
in 2000's American Psycho.
The role went to Hayden Christensen instead,
however.
Oh, what might have been.
“What are you talking about?”
Nothing!
Everything's cool, man.
Colin Hanks as Anakin Skywalker
Like DiCaprio and Bale, Colin Hanks, son of
Tom Hanks, also lost the role of Anakin Skywalker
to Hayden Christensen.
The reason?
Because Christensen's chemistry with Portman
— who was already cast to play Queen Amidala
— was apparently too good to miss.
Hanks probably dodged a bullet: he has a thriving
career, while Christensen is known as the
guy who ruined Darth Vader.
"I hate you!"
The feeling is mutual, buddy.
Tupac Shakur as Mace Windu
The role of Mace Windu seemed to have been
written specifically for lifelong Star Wars
fan Samuel L. Jackson.
But before Jackson got the part, Lucas actually
auditioned other actors for the role — including
legendary rapper Tupac Shakur!
According to Rick Clifford, an audio engineer
at Death Row Records who often spoke with
Tupac about the rapper's budding acting career,
Tupac auditioned for Lucas sometime in 1996,
shortly before The Phantom Menace started
filming.
Unfortunately, Tupac died in a still-unresolved
drive-by shooting later that year, Jackson
ended up with the part, and the rest is history.
"This party's over."
Benicio Del Toro as Darth Maul
If there's a single good thing that came out
of The Phantom Menace, it's Darth Maul.
The guy looks cool, uses a supercool double
lightsaber, and actually made brief moments
of the film watchable.
Before newcomer Ray Park took over the role,
Benicio Del Toro was cast as the spiky Sith
Lord.
But Del Toro, who has a face built for villainy,
left the role when George Lucas cut out most
of Maul's speaking parts, leaving only a lot
of fancy gymnastics.
Good news though: Del Toro will be returning
to the Star Wars universe in Episode VIII.
Michael Jackson as Jar Jar Binks
Of course, for all the good that Darth Maul
brought, there's...this guy.
Yes, Jar Jar Binks, that infamous weirdo from
another planet, is unquestionably the most
controversial character in the Star Wars universe.
Now imagine how much more controversial he
would have been if he had been played by Michael
Jackson, that infamous weirdo from another
planet.
Yes, it's true: while The Phantom Menace was
filming in London, Lucas introduced Jar Jar
actor Ahmed Best to Michael Jackson.
And as it turned out, Jackson had wanted the
role first.
“Michael was kind of lobbying for the role.
He really wanted to do it, but he wanted to
do it with like, prosthetics and makeup.”
Lucas wanted to create a fully computer-generated
character, however, so he cast Best in the
role instead.
At least we'll always have Captain Eo!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!